hi I was wondering in this in this book
we read by David Borenstein in how to
change the world he emphasizes the role
of the social entrepreneur essentially a
philanthropist who approaches social
problems in the same way she might
approach business problems and I was
hoping to gain your perspective on what
you might think about that process and
also how you might approach social
issues you know I've been a little more
in the skeptical camp on the whole
social entrepreneurship notion partly
because what I've seen is is running a
non-profit and doing things for
nonprofit is fundamentally different
than running a for-profit and you know
in spite of what I said earlier about
you know balancing constituents
constituencies I believe that for-profit
has to be a for-profit I mean quite
seriously otherwise it's not going to
survive and endure over the long run and
grow and thrive and a not-for-profit is
a very different thing and and I feel
there's been a little bit of hubris in
my community of saying oh we know better
how to run these nonprofits because
we've run these other companies so well
and some of the things translate and
some of the things don't translate and
are a very different environment and I
feel like there are some really stunning
philanthropies out there who do a
wonderful job of creating enormous value
enormous products services for people
who need it and we shouldn't be
dismissive of them as saying oh they're
not social entrepreneurs I think we
should learn from them because I think
they know a lot about how to do that
right so I feel I feel a little more
respectful of that community that I that
I hear what I hear this sort of social
entrepreneurship notion